I started with one push-up
and every day
I would add a push-up if I couldn't add
a push-up I do the numbers that I'd done
the day before I it's crazy that you're
72 and you're totally jacked you got
like veins coming out of your arm you
can do push-ups all day and on Instagram
you're sharing these videos of you doing
your exercise routine to be able to
share that and let people know that man
part of part of the whole self-loving
thing is to be a part of all of this to
be able to move I just love movement I
love knowing that I can move I love that
and it's very inspiring and it's very
empowering like reframing how we think
about aging but I tell people that I
tell women that with one push-up start
with one inch by inch